y han sido tres años la estrella de
estudio de televisión
[Aplausos]
que este psicólogo es el presentador del
programa semanal conocerse a sí mismo
es el programa estrella de la cadena de
televisión privada gun instante de
a veces uno se pone objetivos para una
semana o un mes y pierde toda la
motivación así que lo deja porque esto
se debe a que no se han fijado los
objetivos adecuados y la motivación es
esencial para alcanzar su meta y es muy
complicado para los psicólogos trabajan
en afganistán estamos en un país muy
pobre un país en guerra y todo esto
afecta considerablemente a la población
muchos están deprimidos o tienen
problemas psicológicos la televisión es
el mejor medio para llegar al mayor
número de personas los profesionales de
la salud mental de afganistán estiman
que el 90 por ciento de la formación
necesita apoyo psicológico en este país
devastado por la guerra un país que
cuenta con menos de 300 psicólogos y
asesores de desarrollo personal para
casi 38 millones de habitantes esta voz
este programa ha tenido un efecto muy
positivo en las personas ya sean cultas
analfabetas a menudo me encuentro con
personas que me dicen que este programa
les ha cambiado la vida
conozco a personas que estaban
deprimidas que querían suicidarse y
mejoraron se disiparán en las ondas
afganas los psicólogos también son los
más populares
la emisora de radio para mujeres que se
lanzó en marzo ya lo está comprobando
este es el programa más escuchado de
radio bq no se dedica a ajmal responde a
las preguntas de los oyentes que a
menudo prefieren permanecer en el
anonimato
cuando ambos padres trabajan todo el día
puede esto tener un impacto negativo en
la educación de los niveles
otros miembros de la familia como las
tías pueden ocuparse de los niños una
niñera porque los niños necesitan un
adulto a su alrededor para crecer de
forma equilibrada
las mujeres son las que más necesitan
apoyo psicológico son las víctimas de
nuestra sociedad la razón por la que
muchas llaman de forma anónima es que
temen ser percibidas como enfermas
mentales su marido puede querer
divorciarse de ellas o tomar una segunda
esposa
a mí da aman con su emisora de radio
quería ofrecer a las mujeres que viven
en la ciudad o en las zonas rurales un
acceso directo y anónimo a los
psicólogos
tenemos muchos otros problemas con los
que lidiar a diario cuando se trata de
mujeres no prestamos atención a estos
problemas los atacamos a los demonios
utilizamos muchos otros métodos para
tratar los métodos más religiosos y
métodos de morábito en lugar de algo
serio y medicalizado
en la universidad de kabul cada vez son
más los estudiantes que se matriculan en
psicología con el deseo de ayudar a los
que sufren mientras ellos mismos padecen
toda la fuerza de la guerra del 2 de
noviembre combatientes del
autodenominado grupo estado islámico
mataron aquí al menos a 22 personas la
mayoría estudiantes en nuestro último
curso hablamos de los síntomas del
trastorno de estrés postraumático quien
puede decirme en cuáles zonas la persona
no puede concentrarse piensa en cosas
terribles que podrían ocurrir y tiene
miedo constantemente
varios de los estudiantes presentes en
el momento de la agresión sufrieron
lesiones físicas y psicológicas
a la universidad de kabul con el
departamento de psicología ha decidido
iniciar la formación en el tratamiento
del trastorno de estrés postraumático y
al final del pasillo
el doctor presa también recibe a
pacientes de fuera de la universidad
como esta joven que prefiere permanecer
en el anonimato me gustaría saber por
qué quería venir a nuestro centro
llevo mucho tiempo en fa dándome por
nada
las cosas insignificantes y el ruido me
hacen enfadar y no puedo controlar
entonces no tiene momento de
desesperación
si por la noche suelo tener pensamientos
oscuros me pregunto qué pasará conmigo
cuando salgo de mi casa pienso que no
voy a llegar vivas porque voy a morir en
un atentado
los jóvenes se interesan más por la
psicología en nuestra sociedad los
problemas psicológicos son más numerosos
debido al contexto general hay atentados
suicidas explosiones que provocan
traumas relacionados con la guerra
el uso del apoyo psicológico parece
estar convirtiéndose gradualmente en
parte de la norma en afganistán donde
más de la mitad de la población padece
trastornos psicológicos y donde el
futuro no pinta bien con la anunciada de
la retirada de las tropas extranjeras el
próximo mes de septiembre